where you gonna be playing next year
yeah I mean you're not gonna get much
right now are you that's gonna do you
know in your head you just can't tell me
no I mean I wish I knew I wish I listen
I got a year under contract there in
Kansas City I mean that's control of
this thing right I mean no I wish I was
the one that got to be able to to do
this that's just not the reality but if
you were in control what would you do we
[Laughter]
you know yeah
listen like I said I mean are you you're
not gonna like this answer at all I mean
I I mean I love I love where I'm at
right I felt like we hundred sheave died
fella we as offensively last year did
some ah you know awesome things you know
so but but who knows or I've been
playing along enough I've been through
this before
I know the trade deal so I'm not not
naive to it you know this is a crazy
business while crazy stuff can happen oh
you'll see open to Cleveland I haven't
even thought about that haven't thought
of it but think about it now yeah one in
31 over the last two years sounds
amazing but but are you looking at a
playoff you're looking at a playoff two
would be ideal right that makes sense
you don't want to go to you would love
to go to a place that if that's the case
if you're going somewhere yeah you want
to go somewhere you have a chance to
yeah success yeah yeah yes
okay I mean I feel it wouldn't you I
don't know look at what I'm surrounded
by I mean I basically went to the
Cleveland Browns of radio shows a lot of
flannel problem no I know but they're
nice guys yeah yeah very very great
personality they office for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show ass
you